[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا
الكرام الم يصبح الجيش العراقي رمزا
للسخريه
والتهكم بعد ان كان من اقوى جيوش المنطقه
في عهد الرئيس الراحل صدام
حسين الا يسمونه الان جيش ابو دشداشه كما
يسمون جيش بشار الاسد جيش ابو
خفافه الا ينهار ما يسمى بالجيش العراقي
كالبسكويت بالرغم من انهم انفقوا عليه
المليارات الم تنفق وزاره الدفاع العراقيه
على الحرب مع داعش اكثر مما انفقته امريكا
في حربها على العراق عام
2003 الا يهرب الاف الجنود العراقيين
كالفئران
المذعوره امام 100 مقاتل من تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه يتساءل ابو عمر العراقي الا
يسقط منه المئات يوميا في معارك
بسيطه الم يصبح الحشد الشيعي اقوى من
الجيش العراقي بمرات مرات يتساءل
ضيفنا ماذا كان سيفعل الجيش العراقي لولا
الغطاء الجوي الامريكي
والايراني الم تتشدق القياده العسكريه
العراقيه بانها ستستعيد الموصل فخسرت
الرمادي لكن في المقابل الا يواجه الجيش
العراقي البطل اعتى الجماعات الارهابيه في
العالم الم يتمكن من تحرير مدينه تكريت
قبل فتره من قبل قضه داعش وبالامس حرر
مدينه بيجي النفطيه
الاستراتيجيه اليس من الاجحاف اتهامه بانه
جيش
طائفي الا يفتقر الجيش العراقي الى السلاح
النوعي الم يحصل على اسلحه فاسده الم
تتراجع امريكا عن تزويده بالسلاح المطلوب
ما العيب في ان يستعين الجيش بالحشد
الشعبي الا تلجا الجيوش عاده الى تشكيل
فصائل رديف
اوقات الحروب والازمات
اليست القوات المسلحه العراقيه قادره على
طرد فلول تنظيم داعش الارهابي التكفيري
الظلامي من العراق عاجلا او
اجلا اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره على
السيد سرمد عبد الكريم مدير وكاله الاخبار
العراقيه وعلى السيد علاء الخطيب الكاتب
والاعلامي العراقي نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان الجيش العراقي جيش
طائفي متهالك ام جيش قوي
متجانس
95.8 جيش طائفي متهالك
4.2
قوي متجانس سيد عبد الكريم لو بدات معك
بهذه النتيجه ما الذي يدفع كل هؤلاء يعني
نتيجه هائله بغض النظر دقيقه مش دقيقه راح
تقول لي مش دقيقه وانا بقول لك مش دقيقه
بس يعني نسبه هائله
جدا كيف تفسر ذلك انه هذا الجيش يعني
طائفي كذا اصبح مصدرا او رمزا للسخريه
والتهكم يعني دكتور بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اولا دكتور لازم نعرف بانه الجيوش
هي وليده دول وليست وليده شركات او محلات
بيع الخرده بيع الخرده اي طبعا يعني ما
يحكم العراق بيع خرده الان نعم بالضبط هذا
اللي قاعد يصير تعرف انت الدوله العراقيه
سنه 21 الهاشمين ملك فيصل الاول غازي
الملك فيصل الثاني وخاله كان الوصي على
العرش اسسوا الجيش من 21 الى 21 هذا الجيش
بدا يتدرب ويتجهز الى 41 دخل اول معركه ب
48 دخل الى معركه فلسطين
وا مقبره شهداء الجيش العراقي في فلسطين
شاهد على طبيعه ال الشعب العراقي في ذلك
الوقت تلقى الكردي والتركماني والشيعي
والسني
والمسيحي جيش امه جيش جيش امه نعم جيش بلد
هذا الجيش ظل يتطور اصبح مدرسه اصبح ال
قيم وشارك في كل المهمات القوميه لكن بعد
ان صار الاحتلال هناك زواج يا دكتور غير
شرعي بين الاحتلال الامريكي والاحتلال
الايراني نتج عن هذا الزواج غير شرعي ابن
غير شرعي اللي هو هذا ما يسمى بالجيش وهو
ما له علاقه بالجيش يعني الجيش العراقي
الحالي
نعم نعم هذا هذا هذا ابن غير شرعي
لدوله غير شرعيه هذه الدوله شكلت من ناس
اجوا من خارج العراق ومعظمهم ولاءاتهم
خارج الحدود وكلهم دفعوا مصاري وفلوس حتى
يشترون مناصب تدري يا دكتور احنا بالعراق
ما عندنا ترى بورصه مثل باقي الدول للاسهم
والشركات مثل ما تطلع بالاخبار عندكم
بالجزيره وغيرها لكن عندنا بورصه لشراء
المناصب الوزاريه والرتب العسكريه و
العسكريه تباع وتشت في العرا نعم ما نعطيك
الاسعار يعني اخر اسعار قائد فرقه 500000
دولار و1000 دولار شهريا امر لواء 250,000
دولار و000 دولار شهريا امر فوج او كتيبه
150,000 دولار و25000 دولار شهريا هذا
يتبع طبيعه الفرقه او التشكيل او اللواء
حسب وجوده اذا كان هذا في مكان خطر او
حساس ترتفع القيمه لانه هذا امر اللواء او
قائد الفرقه يتلقى الرواتب مال الجنود
الفضائيين اللي ما لهم وجود هنالك 50 الف
جندي فضائي يا دكتور شو فضائي يعني فضائي
يعني طاير بالهواء يعني ما له اي وجود
يعني يعني هناك ميزانيه عليه هو فقط اسم
على القوائم ياخذ امر اللواء او قائد
الفرقه او رئيس الحكومه اللي هو قائد عام
القوات مسلحه ياخذ الفلوس يحط مضبط مثل
الضباط السوريين ايام زمان حتى الان يعني
بالضبط هي هذه المساله فلذلك من هكذا جيش
يتشكل بهكذا طريقه لا تدريب لا مصلحه
وطنيه لا عقيده بالتالي سيصل الى نتيجه
غريبه انا اقول لك الشغله صارت شنو
بالحقيقه الجنود المنتمين للجيش العراقي
الحالي هم جنود اجوا فقط لغرض الراتب طبعا
مع العلم ها فضائيين يعني كل جندي طيفه 50
60 جندي فضائي ما له وجود هذا الجندي اجى
لانه لا يوجد امامه غير هذا المسلك للحصول
على راتب حتى يعيش عائلته او اما الشرطه
او الجيش من تصير معركه لا عند الهدف ولا
عند القابليه للدفاع يا دكتور عن العراق
لانه ما يؤمن بهذه المساله ولا يامن بهذا
الجيش وحقيقه
شكل ابدا عش عشائريا وطائفيا وهنالك دول
اخرى يا دكتور تشارك وتوجه هذا الجيش بس
لحظه هيي نقطه مهمه باختصار شديد المساله
الخطيره هذا الجيش يوجه ويدرب ويسل من دول
اخرى ليست لها علاقه بالعراق وبالتالي
اصبحت هذه الدول هي اللي تتحكم وقياده
الجيش انا اسال وين وين الجيش نعم جميل
جدا كيف ترد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في
البدايه طبعا هذه المقدمه التحريضيه اللي
قدمتوها انتم وكذلك
نتيجه الاستطلاع تثبت على انه هناك
ممارسات مورست من قبل الاعلام العربي
وكذلك مورست من قبل دواعش السياسه وخونه
العراق ضد الجيش العراقي وضد العراق وضد
هذه العمليه السياسيه بالتاكيد هذه الحرب
النفسيه بدات من الولايات المتحده عندما
وصفت الجيش العراقي بانه عديم الرغبه في
القتال عندما
وصفت قالت ان داعش ستبقى الى ثلاث سنوات
عندما قالت ان الحرب على داعش سوف يعني
تتكلف ب 500 مليار كل هذه حقيقه الحرب
النفسيه الحرب النفسيه وليس الاعلاميه
الحرب النفسيه التي مونست من قبل الاعلام
العربي ولعل الجزيره واحده من من القنوات
التي تصدرت يعني بالاعتداء على على الشعب
العراقي والاعتداء على الجيش العراقي
وكذلك هناك حرب الاشاعات هذه حمله الدعايا
والاشاعات التي ظهرت في من هنا وهناك
حقيقه ايضا هناك ممارسات لا اخلاقيه مورست
من قبل الاعلام العربي والاعلام العربي هو
مقصر لم لحد الان منذ 2003 ولحد هذه
اللحظه الاعلام العربي لم يسلط الضوء على
منجز عراقي واحد على منجز عراقي ولكن هذا
الاعلام هذا الاعلام العربي كثير من
المنجز بدي اسالك المنجزات العسكريه
بعكم الم فقط ليس
فقط هزم واح ليس فقط الجيش العراقي ولكن
كل المنجزات يعني الان يسلط الضوء على
ازمه النازحين يسلط الضوء على ازمه
النازحين على سبيل المثال ضو على ازمه
النازحين ولكن لا احد يذكر ان هناك الاف
من النازحين يسكنون في كربلاء والنجف
والمدن الشيعيه دعني اكمل د كم لا دعني
يكمل دعني كمل دعني يكمل نعم هناك ايضا
هنا نعم بالجيش بالجيش هناك ايضا حقيقه
يعني حمله موجهه ومنظمه ضد الجيش العراقي
وضد ويقال انه هذا الجيش طائفي دعني حقيقه
افسر لك ما هي طائفيه هذا الجيش لا لا لا
خل خليني خليني ا شوف الان يعني حقيقه انا
اقول لك الاشاعه التي انطلقت في قضيه
الثلاجه و اش سقيفه وتناقل تناقلتها
القنوات العربيه بكل يعني فرح وكانه
انتصار كبير للاعلام العربي عندما تشوه
سمعه المقاتلين العراقيين ال يدافعون عن
الارض هؤلاء الذين ضحوا بارواحهم وبدماء
نعم اقول لك يعني هنا هنا يعني اكذوبه
كبيره هي طائفيه الجيش العراقي ودعني اعدد
لك اولا وزير الدفاع هو خالد متعب العبيدي
سني رئيس اركان الجيش ابو بكر زيباري سني
قائد القوه الجويه انور حمى امين سني قائد
القوه البريه رياض جليل توفيق سني مدير
الاداره والمير والتموين نجيب احمد سني
مدير التخطيط العسكري والعمليات مجيد
اللهيبي سني امر دائره الاداره في وزاره
الدفاع مزهر شاهر نصيف سني قائد عمليه
الجزيره والباديه ناصر احمد سني الهيتي
سني قائد قوات عشائر الانبار زياد طارق
العلواني سني قائد عمليات صلاح الدين جمعه
نادي الجبوري سني نائب رئيس الاركان مرضي
المحلاوي سني قائد عمليات الانبار قاسم
المحمدي سني قائد الشرطه الاتحاديه هدايه
عبد الكريم سني وكل هذا ونقول انه هذا ز
خلي سؤال صغيري سؤال صغير بس سؤال صغير
البعض يقول مع كل سني وزير كذا سني سني
سني سني معك معك هذول صبنا فيهم مثل الجيش
السني السوري عننا بسوريا 80% من الجيش
سني بس هال 80 ضابط وال 9000 ضابط شقفه
صرمايه علوي عريف بيسوى قرش مصدي بيسوى
صرم اهم كل
هول
هذا كانيا النظام
البحثه كان نقيبي العراقي انا اقول لك انه
كان في ايام النظام البحثي نعم هذا الشيء
موجود اما الان غير موجود والان وزاره
الدفاع من يحكمها وزاره الدفاع لا يحكمها
الشيعه يحكمها السنه يعني الان خالد
العبيدي السني وهو
الذيي وكذا الى اخره كل هذه القضايا وقول
انه هناك بس دقيقه بس مشان نوضح نقطه مهمه
اذا عم تتهم السيد سرمد عبد الكريم بانه
طائفي هو شيعي
مثلك
[موسيقى]
اليشر اخذ دورك وحكيت كلام را اولا هذا
الكلام بالنسبه الى وزاره الدفاع وزير
الدفاع سني رئيس الاركان سني الى اخره هذا
هو رئيس الاركان يا دكتور لكن مخرج ش ابو
بكر هذا رئيس الاركان النائم هذا هو السني
بس لا توجد وزاره دفاع بالعراق ولا توجد
رئاسه تركان
التاج انت تقاطع
تخاف نعم مخرج وقف البرنامج ارجوك وقف
البر ليه مثل ما حكيت خليه يحكي وانت خطري
هذ تفضل تفضل لا توجد عندنا في العراق
وزاره دفاع ولا توجد هيئه اركان ولا توجد
رئاسه اركان ولا توجد قياده عا قوات مسلحه
انت بتحكي هون احسن مشان الكاميرا تاخ
لحتى تكون الامور بشكل واضح اولا وين رئيس
الاركان هسه احنا عندنا حرب وجوديه في
العراق العراق محتل 45 50% من عند عن داعش
وين رئيس اركان يوم شفت الرئيس الاركان
طلع فتش قطاعات راح للجبل لا يجد رس اركان
وزير الفاع ياخذ صور مع مع وسائل الاعلام
مع النساء وغيرهم ما عندنا وزار دفاع ليش
لان ما عندنا
جيش انت ماحق تقاطع لان تخاف الحقاق المه
المساله الاخرى اللي نتكلم عنها بكل بساطه
هنالك ما يسمى بالحشد الشعبي اللي هي
مليشيات تم دمجها شوف دكتور منذ البدايه
من ايام ابراهيم لولا الحشد الشعبي ليس
هناك لا عزه ولا كرامه ولا رف راس
العراقين الحد الشعبي
هوخ دقيقه دقيقه نعود اليكم نعود اليكم
بعد هذا
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى تفضل دكتور
بساطه شديده بانه مساله الجيش الجيش لا
يوجد جيش في العراق ولا توجد وزاره دفاع
ولا توجد رئسه اركان هذه كلها كلمات
ومناصب فاشله ليست لها علاقه لا بالحكومه
ولا بالعراق اصلا يعني مثل الجيش السوري
مثل ما قص بال خلقوا ما يسمى بالحشد بناء
على فتوى كفائي من السستاني هذه الفتوى
بالحقيقه مصلحتها ايرانيه جابوا المليشيات
وهي سياسه مستمره منذ ايام ابراهيم
الجعفري دمج الميليشيات بقرار رسمي شنو
هي بدر هذه المؤسسات عفوا بدر وغيرها من
المليشيات كانت تقاتل الجيش العراقي اثناء
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه في الجانب
الايراني العامري وغير العامري هسه يتكلم
هو على على السنه هسه رح نحكي على الشيعه
العامري وغير العامري كانوا في الجانب
الايراني يعذبون الاسرى ويقتلون الضباط
وهذا هو هادي العامري الان هو بالقيادات
خلنا نتكلم قاسم سليماني ايش وظف وظف جمال
جعفر محمد علي الابراهيم اللي يسموه ابو
مهدي المهندس ابو مهدي المهندس ارهابي
دولي من المتهمين بقتل ومحاوله اغتيال
امير الكويت هو الان احد الشخصيات نائب
رئيس الحشد الشعبي اللي هي مليشيات متطرفه
طائفيه عاقده ايرانيه الولاء ليس لها
علاقه بالعراق لا من قريب ومن بعيد ايضا
هادي العامري قائد قوات بدر صادق عبد
الامير محمد السعداوي المرقب ابو فرقد
لبناء وتاسيس مؤسسه مشابه لحرس الثوري
الايراني رسميا في العراق صارت هنالك كوبي
او نسخه او فيرجن من هذه الحرس الثوري
الارهابي لفيلق القدس الارهابي اللي قوده
سليماني جابوه وحطوه في العراق ويحطوه في
سوريا ويحطوه في لبنان ويحطوه هذه السياسه
هي سياسه خلق اذرع ايرانيه ولذلك من مهمه
هذه الاذرع انهاء الجيش
العراقي ايران لا تريد جيشا في العراق
ابدا وتريد هذا ما يسمى بالحرس الثوري هو
نفسه هذه الميليشيات الان تحت غطاء الحشد
الشعبي وبذلك اصبح هذا الحشد عباره عن
سرطان ياكل العراق بكل شيء بماله بحركاته
بارضه ولعلمك دكتور لم تجري معارك في
تكريت او في الانبار او في الموصل وانما
عمليه بيع وشراء لهذه المناطق بين تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه وبين هذه الميليشيات
تكريت مثلا تكريت مثلا لم تجري معركه
وانما تم شراء تكريت في 70 مليار دينار
واتحدى يطلعونا يطلعونا الحشد الشعبي جثه
واحد من داعش في تكريت اثناء
المعركه كثيره
موج بالنسبه لبار بالنسبه لبار
اذا مره قاطعت ما خ تتكلم نهائيا لا تقاطع
زين تقاع ما من حقك تحكي انت لا تقاطع تخق
النقطه الاخيره النقطه الاخيره الانبار يا
دكتور هسه انت من واحد يهرب عندك همار
وعندك سياره تتحرك السياره ليش تخلي
السياره وتخلي سلاحك وتنزع ملابسك وتدفع
بالدشداشه قيمه السياره حتى تخلص بنفسك
دكتور انا اصحح لك المعلومه مو 100 شخص
هجموا على الانبار 50 شخص شخص لان القوه
المهاجمه 150 قتلوا منهم الامريكان 100
وبقوا 50 اللي هم استولوا على الرمادي 50
شخص مقابل الفرقه الذهبيه العراقيه القائد
برواري وقيادات وسيارات وهمت ومعدات 500
همر وسياره في الموصل والانبار اللي
انطاها الامريكان واشتراها العراق من
امواله راحت الى داعش هديه لمساعده مناء
قياده القوات العسكريه في تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ببساطه شديده
ال تزير ايران ورا والغ منها انهاء العراق
وال لي العراق فقط واضح دكتور ودخولهم الى
منطقه النخيب الى غرض اخر عل خليك تفضل
الك الوقت كاملا بدون اي مقاطعه شرف يا
سي طبعا ما يخص الحشد الشعبي الحجد الشعبي
هو جاج كره فعل الحجد
الشعب انت مثل ما
انطيت هو ذكر ذكر نقاط مهمه دعني اجيب على
هذه الق اولا الحشد الشعبي جاء كرد فعل
وليس فعل هو رد فعل على الارهابيين
ودخولهم وبالتاكيد كل بلد عندما يتعرض الى
الخطر هناك فصائل شعبيه رديفه هذا موجود
هذا حصل وين حصل عندنا في الاتحاد
السوفيتي وحصل عندنا في الصول وكل الاماكن
حقيقه يحصل عندما يتعرض البلد الى خطر
انتهي كل شي اما هذا الحشد اليوم اللي
اعاد العزه والكرامه للعراقيين هذا الحشد
اليوم حر البارح حرر بيجي وحرر الصقلاويه
وح وحرر وحرر كذلك دياله وحرر صلاح الدين
وحرر بعدين هذا الحشد قد رمى اسهم اسهم
بكل قلوب الخائنين يعني انا انا حقيقه اقف
اجلالا لبدر شاكر السياب عندما يقول اني
لا اعجب ان يخون الخائنون ايخون انسان
بلاده كيف تخون بلادك هذا بلد هؤلاء هبوا
لنصره العراق فلا يمكن حقيقه ان ان ان
نموس بهم هذا واحد الشيء الاخر اما ما يخص
انه الدمج ليس هناك من القيادات العراقيه
اليوم في الجيش العراقي لا امراء الويه
ولا قاده فرق ولا امراء سرايا ليس هناك
احد من هؤلاء من الدمج ابدا هؤلاء الدمج
الدمج الدمج هم عباره عن المقاتلين الذي
كانوا يقاتلون ضد الدكتاتوريه ضد البحثين
وضد صدام حسين في ايام المعارضه العراقيه
عندما عادوا عادوا ودخلوا الى الجيش وهذه
التجربه ليست تجربه عراقيه وليست فريده من
نوعها يعني الجيش الاحمر في الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان اغلب قيادته ماركسيه عندما
انتصرت الثوره الروسيه دخل هذا الجيش
واصبح كذلك انصار ديغول كانوا عندما دخل
الالمان الى فرنسا شكلوا انصار ودخلوا بعد
ذلك انصهروا في الجيش اذا التجربه هي ليست
تجربه عراقيه وهؤلاء لا يمثلون اقل اقل من
10% اقل ليس من الجيش من كل قوى الامن
والجيش يعني عندنا اليوم 350 الف مثلا في
الشرطه الاتحاديه لا يمثلون اكثر من 3500
واحد موجودين اللي هو الحشد الحشد مو
الحشد لا لا لا قوات الدمج الذ يتح تحدثون
عنها نعم هذه القضايا يجب ان تحط في مقياس
هذه في في مكانها ويجب ان نقول عليها كذا
اما ما يخص انه الحشد قد تامر على العراق
مع داعش فهذه لعمري انها كذبه كبيره جدا
50 واحد يعني اليوم اليوم حقيقه الطائرات
الامريكيه رصدت بعض مضادات الدروع
والقاذفات الايرانيه التي عبرت الى سوريا
كما تدعي وعبرت الى العراق عبر الاراضي
العراقيه ور عبر الاقمار الصناعيه الايس
الاحرى بالولايات المتحده ان ترصد تحركات
داعش بهذه الاميال الطويله الت تتحرك بها
اذا هل من المعقول انه ن نرمي اللوم على
الجيش العراقي وعلى المقاتلين ولا نرم ولا
نرمي نقول انه امريكا ايضا هي مقصره في
هذا الجانب امريكا هي ايضا صاحبه حقيقه
التقصير الاكبر لانه عدم التسليع بعدين
اقول لك شيء مهم جدا احنا عندنا اليوم
عندنا اليوم اليوم اليوم دواعش السياسه
اخطر من الدواعش الذين يقات
دواع السياه اقول دواعش السياسه عندما
يخرج وزير الدفاع على سبيل المال ويقول ان
الاغبياء هم الذين يذهبون الى الكليه
العسكريه وهو يهين العسكر والضباط
العراقيين لا يمكن للضباط هؤلاء ان يكونوا
كما يريد وزير الدفاع عندما يخرج رئيس
مجلس النواب العراقي ويقول انني اشكك في
قدره الجيش العراقي على تحرير الانبار هذا
معناه ماذا معنا هذه رسائل من هؤلاء الى
الدواعش ناهيك عن هؤلاء الذين يتحدثون عن
عدم مهنيه بس دقيقه بس خليني اسالك سؤال
كلام جميل جدا لكن انت تتحدث عن القياده
العراقيه هل العراق الق القياده العراقيه
التي تقود الجيش العراقي وعلى راس البلد
خائنه انت عم تخونهم الان انا لا اقول
خائنه بلا خائنه ونص يا سيدي حسب كلامك
خائن لا لا لا لم اقول خا انا انا اتحدث
عن الجيش كمؤسسه منظومه دفاعيه انا لا
اتحدث عن عن وزير الدفاع وفلان هؤلاء جاءت
بهم المحاصه هؤلاء لم ياتوا عبر بسان انت
قبل شوي عملت لي وزير الدفاع العراقي اهم
من شنكليش الحنكش لا لا ما ق لا انا قلت
انه سني انت انت اليوم قلت لي انه الجيش
العراقي طائفي حطيت لي بين قوسين طائفي
فاجبت انه اغلب القيادات العراقيه
الموجوده في وزاره الدفاع ورئاسه الاركان
هي قيادات سنيه وليست شيعيه هذه التهمه
التي يروجها الاعلام العربي هذه التهمه
التي تروجها الجزيره احيان ماشي ماشي
جزيره ماشي جزيره ماشي سيد سرمات بس بدي
اساله سؤال سريع بس بدي اسالك سؤال هذا
السؤال يسال الكثير من العراقيين والعرب
اه البعض يقول لك اه انه الميزانيه الضخمه
التي تعادل ربع ميزانيه العراق تذهب للجيش
العراقي تثير الفاسدين بلغت 25 مليار
دولار 25 مليار دولار اه ب 2015 ومضى يعني
هذه شغله ما صرفته وزاره الدفاع العراقيه
على الحرب مع داعش فاق ما انفقته حرب
الولايات المتحده على العراق 2003 ومشان
ما تقول لي جايب الكلام من عندك هذا عضو
لجنه هذا عضو لجنه الامن والدفاع
البرلمانيه النائب علي المتيوي عن وجو حكى
الرجل طب انا بدي اسال بدي اس بدي اسال بس
انا لشارع طيب هذا الجيش العراقي الذي
يدفع عليه المليارات لماذا يهرب كالجرذان
المذعوره الجيش لم يهرب اولا القيادات
عندما تنسحب نعم هناك حقيقه تواط في
الموصل حصل وهذا واضح للجميع عندما انسحب
قائد الشرطه الاتحاديه وهدايه عبد الكريم
انسحب بالتواطؤ مع جهات عراقيه انه
ينسحبون الموصل عندما الان المجلس النواب
العراقي يصوب على يصوت على ازاله او او
استقاله اثير النجيفي وهذا معناه انه هو
في دائره الاتهام كذلك هناك حقيقه من
القيادات العسكريه العراقيه كالغراب وغيره
وغيره وغيره انا ما اتذكر كل هؤلاء
بالمناسبه دعني اقول شيء مهم جدا اسمح لي
دكتور فيصل دكتور في
شوف اسمحلي اسمحلي خل اقوللك شيء واحد مهم
انه كل القيادات اللي ذكرناها من عبود
قنبر الى مهدي الغراوي الى علي غيدان الى
هؤلاء الان القوات اللي موجوده كلها كل
هذه ضباط النظام السابق وليس
ضباط لم ي حزب
الدعوه وصلت وصلت لا انا بدي اسالك المال
بدي اسالك م المسال طيب نحن لماذا لماذا
نتجاهل او ننكر بان هناك ازمه سلاح انفق
الكثير من المال على الجيش العراقي لكن
امريكا تراجعت اه او غدرت بالجيش العراقي
لم تقدم للجيش العراقي السلاح النوعي
المطلوب حتى الكثير من صفقات الاسلحه التي
وقعها المالكي كانت صفقات فاسده المشكله
ليست في الج الجندي العراقي الحالي هو
جندي قوي شجاع بطل المشكله في السلاح نعم
اذا المشكله مش ليست مال انفق مال بس هذا
المال لا ياتي لك بسلاح تطي ان تقاتل به
كيف ترد يا دكتور فقط بالموصل سلاح فرقتين
عسكريه زائدا فرقه شرطه اتحاديه راحت اديه
داعش من ضمنها دبابات برامز المتطوره جدا
والتي ما كان يملكها الجيش العراقي هنالك
صواريخ هنالك صواريخ ارض جو راحت فرقتين
زائد فرقه هناك سلاح كبير سلاح كبير جدا
تقدم هديه بل هنالك 500 اليه عسكريه تركها
الجيش وطلع راح بعدها قسم منها بزيتها قسم
منها بجيتها بعد طيب الى ماذا تعزو ذلك
لماذا هذا هرب الجيش هرب لانه لا يوجد لا
يوجد جندي اولا هنالك مقرب من العبادي علي
العلاق وهو من القيادات المعروفه عند
المالكي طيب يقول ما سماهم العملاء اللي
هم في الحكومه السابقه تسببه بانتكاسات
الرمادي شو يقول كشف العلاق خلال جلسه عن
سقوط مد رمادي مركز محضه الانبار عن تلقي
عدد من القاده العسكريين رسائل نصيه من
سياسيين عراقيين مرتبطين برئيس الوزراء
السابق المالكي يطلب منه الانسحاب وانسحبت
الفرقه الذهبيه بطريقه غريبه عجيبه بل
هنالك معلومات تشير بانه قائد الفرقه اجبر
قوات فرق اثنين بالانسحاب فورا من المنطقه
والا سيعدم هذا الكلام موثق تسالني عن
القيادات بدي اسالك لا بدي اسالك بس بدي
اسلا بدي اسالك سؤال انت لماذا تحاول ان
تتجاهل او تنكر ان هذا الجيش العراقي
البطل نعم يواجه اعتى الارهابيين
الظلاميين التكفيريين في العالم يعني انت
لماذا تحاول ان تتجاهل هذه النقطه هذه
القوى التي يواجهها الجيش العراقي ليست
قوى عاديه قوى قوى شرسه جدا مدربه كل هذا
الكلام لماذا انت تقول لي سلموا ما سلموا
غير صحيح انا اسال دكتور عمليه سقوط
الموصل تمت بساعات ولا بيوم ما هم شايفين
قدامهم هذا العدو الموجود صار لهم سنوات
يصيحون
والتكفيريين والقاعده وغيرها و هذا الكلام
كله قدامهم كان موجود شنو اللي حدث في يوم
وليله ف وجت ان جت داعش ودخلت يا دكتور
المساله ليست كذلك احنا لازم نرجع لاسباب
الحقيقيه ما حدث في الرمادي هنالك تجمعات
سلميه طلعوا والاهالي يطالبون بحقوقهم سنه
كامله قوات الجيش العراقي البطل ها تتكلم
عنها تعتدي على الناس العزل بالسلاح اللي
هي قوات المالكي وتسرق المحلات كما شاهدنا
في تكريت وتكريت وتذهب هذه العجلات
والقوات البطله اللي سميتها تروح المعسكر
اشرف بالهمر تدعس الناس
امام الكاميرات وتقتل الناس ها هي القوات
والان دقيقه دقيقه
دقيقه انت مذيع انت مو
مذ اكملي اكملي تفضل معسكر اشرف الهمرات
راحت على الناس العزل على السلاح معسكر
اشرف دهستهم دهس بدون سلاح ما عندهم
طلقه نقطه وهنالك قوه اليوم عسكريه بطله
تحاصر معسكر ليبرتي تمنع عنهم الماء
والدواء واي شي ايو هذه وجبه اقول ما يلي
هذا الجيش هو جيش طائفي بامتياز وموجه من
ايران وجيش فاسد كما هي اجهزه الدوله
الفاسده لا يوجد جيش بالحقيقه لانه الجنود
الموجودين فقط اسماع الورق يعني عندك لواء
مثلا 3000 شخص 3000 جندي حقيقه هذا اللواء
ما ما تتجاوز ال 200 200 شخص هذه الرواتب
تحول لامر اللواء وتحول لقائد الفرقه
وتحول الى القائد العام للقوات المسلحه بس
اسلك سؤال يا دكتور نوري المالك كان يشتغل
قبل كرش وزراء شلون اليوم واحد من من اكبر
رؤساء اصحاب رؤساء الموال بالعالم تعرف
انت اليوم بها العرجي مثلا هذه الاسماء و
مسؤول عن كلامي اليوم يلعب مش 10 مليار
لان هذا الفساد هو اللي وصل يا اخي انت
مذيع الفساد الفساد هو في قلب الجيش
الفساد وصل وصل الى مرحله وصل الى مرحله
لا تستطيع ان تقوم قوات عسكريه بس المشكله
مو دكتور حتى روسيا فضحت الصفقه الاخيره
بين الفساد الفساد كمل خلي اكمل
النقطه المساله ليست هي ه هذه القوات
وانما حقيقه ايش راح يصير يعني الان الجيش
العراقي يقول العبادي راح نحرر الرمادي
خلال ايام هذا تصريح رسمي قائد العام
القوات المسلحه كيف تحرر الرمادي خلال
الايام وجيشك الفرقه الذهبيه اللي انسحبت
تركض وما تلحق يعني لو اجيب فنان يا دكتور
يرسم لي لوحه تقول له تعال ارسم لوحه
يقوللك اريد الاسبوع كيف انت خلال ايام
راح تستعيد الرمادي هذه المهزله لانه لا
توجد هناك كفاءات لا توجد استشارات وانما
هنالك دوله ترسل بالفاكس
وبالايمان الى العبادي وغير العبادي اضل
تفضل ايران تفضل ها هي القياده العسكريه
نتكلم عنها خلي الاخ المخرج شوف القياده
العسكريه ضباط الركن يتلقون التعليمات من
هذا الشخص شوف يا دكتور هذه هي القيادات
العسكريه شوف هادي العامري هذا هو البطل
اللي تحكي عنه هادي العامري هو يوجه
التعليمات الان الى ضباط الركن اللي هم
قاده عسكريين امامه كيف تريد من جيش يحركه
شخص كان ما اللهه علاقه بالجيش تدري انت
رساء الحكومات ثلاثه ثلاثه من رساء
الحكومات اللي صاروا بالعراق لم يخدموا
خدمه عسكريه بالج جميل جدا طيب انا اسالك
طيب انت لماذا تحاول ان تتجاهل ايضا مثل
ما سالته ان ايران كما يقول الكثيرون لا
تريد جيشا قويا في العراق يعني ايران تريد
ان تنتقم من الجيش العراقي بتاع زمان
البطل الذي ادمى انفها لسنوات وسنوات
وانتصر عليها جعل الخميني يعترف بانه تجرع
السم ا عم بقول لك التدخل الايراني
ايران شغلت
يعني ايران اخذت كل المواقع النفوذ الكبرى
في العراق بعد الانسحاب الامريكي عام 2011
ونسقت مع الحكومه العراقيه باستمرار ضمن
عده اتفاقيات عسكريه وامنيه مشتركه وتحاول
ايران باستمرار تقويه نفوذها في العراق
عبر الدعم غير المحدود لميليشيات الحشد
الشيعي الشعبي ليقوى جانبه على حساب قوه
الجيش الرسمي نفسه علما بان التمركز
الشيعي في الحكومه والجيش والامن الذي
تسببت به القرارات الامريكيه وزاد منه
لاحقا التدخل الايراني هو امر يثير
الاستياء العراقي ايران عم بقول لك ليش
مثلا الان هل تستطيع ان تنكر انه الحشد
الشيعي الشعبي اصبح اقوى بمرات ومرات من
الجيش العراقي لانه هناك رغبه ايرانيه شوف
ايران لم تطلق ايران لم تطلق لفظ الجيش
المالكي ولا الجيش الصفوي على الجيش الع
جميل وانما اطلقها العرب واطلقها دواعش
السياسه واطلقها الخونه نعم اقول لك ان
الحشد الشعبي وليس حجدا شيعيا اليوم هي
منظمه حكوميه مؤسسه تحت قياده القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه فعندما الان من الذي
من الذي افتى به من الذي افتى به بتشكيل
الحشد الشعبي مزاره الدفاع وستان لا لا
مرجعنا الكبير السيد السست شو دخل
السيستاني بالجيش نعم السيد
السيستاني
يا حبيبي لواء بالجيش السيستاني خليني
اجاوب خليني اجاوب دكتور فيصل خل ا اخي
دقيقه انا بديال تال السيستاني شو علاقته
بالجيش يا سيدي السيد السيستاني هو صمام
امان العراق السيد السيستاني هو في
البدايه في العمليه السياسيه وفي كتابه
الدستور وعدم
ي دقيقه
ضل تل كمل كمل كمل السيد السيستاني صمام
امان العراق الله يحفظه لولا السيد
السيستاني
واعش دخل الى بغدا ولا والف ولو الفتوى
الشهيره ل السيستاني التي حفظت العراق
وحفظت ابناء العراق وحفظت المقدسات لم يكن
لم يعد هناك
عراق الم يكن من الافضل الم يكن من الافضل
انت عم تقول نحن بحاجه لفصائل رديفه للجيش
الم يكن من الافضل ان يصدر ذلك عن رئيس
الدوله عن رئيس الوزراء او عن وزير الدفاع
ليش اخذ صفه طائفيه سيستان لم لم ياخذ هذه
الصفه الطائيه فقط في ادمغتهم ليس موجوده
ليعم
مجاني درزي مش
هيك هوجي عجبني دكتور فيصل انا اللي عجبني
انت درزي ما ادري ليش رايح لطائف اخي انا
عمالك يا حبيبي السيستاني السستاني شيعي
السستاني مرجع
شيعي
السعوديه دقيقه دقيقه انتم تتحدثون الان
عن الطائفيه بالجيش العراقي اسالك بالله
وانا راح اسال الشعب العربي كله هل هناك
ضابط او جندي في السعوديه شيعي هل هناك في
البحرين رغم الاكثريه الشيعيه هناك ضابط
او جندي شيعي هل هناك في قطر هنا جندي
شيعي ليس هناك اي شيع هذ مو
طائف والله انت مش عار حالك وين والله مش
عار كلامك كذ صحيح
صحيح انا بدي بس يا اخي بس جاوبني على
السؤال جاوبني على السؤال جاوبني على
السؤال في 100000 واحد 100000 واحد انا
بدي اسالك سؤال بتقول لي الجيش العراقي
ليس جيشا طائفيا والحشد الشعبي ليس حشدا
شيعيا ليش افتى في سيس ثاني السستاني مرجع
انت ما فاهم
القضيه دقي لا دعني اقول لك شوف بالنسبه
انت انتم من اطلقت جيش المالكي وجيش
الصفوي
والان سيدي خبي على السؤال دكتور فيصل يا
دكتور فيصل داعش منظمه ارهابيه مصنفه
عالميا ارهابيه
الان هذه الان الصحف العربيه لم تطلق كلمه
داعش ولم تقول المجامع الارهابيه وانما
تقول يستهدف الدوله الاسلاميه وتنظيم
الدوله هذا هو حقيقه الاعلام العربي الذي
يوشي يشوه كل نصر عراقي لماذا تشوه النصر
العراقي انا ما اعرف ليش كل نصر عراقي
تشص بس دقيقه والله بدي ارح بدي اسالك بدي
اسال ماشي ماشي ماشي انا بدي ارجع لا لا
لا انا بدي ارجع لك انا بدي ارجع لك يا
اخي انا بدي اسالك مثل ما سالته قال لك
بهمو الجماعه ققول لك انت كذا
وكذا انت زعلان ليش الحشد الشعبي نعم افتى
بتشكيله مرجع شيعي ديني وليس وزير الدفاع
العراقي ولا رئيس الجمهوريه العراقي ولا
رئيس الحكومه العراقي مش هيك عم اقول لك
الرجل لولا
العظيم السيس تاني السيس اني لا خ
العراق يا اخي مش يا اخي انا عم بقول لك
نفس كلامك يا زلمه دقيقه السيد السيستاني
لولا فتواه العظيمه لذهب العراق في 6 الف
داهيه انا اقوللك على
السيد تتكلم عننا مو انا اقول رامسفلد
وزير الدفاع في مذكراته يقول هدينا
السستاني 200 مليون دولار هديه تليق
الولايات
المتحده
السياس السيستاني كمرجع على راس الجميع
انسان عظيم جدا نحن عم نحكي سياسي الان
احكي سياسي وتركي الرجل الرجل
احترام انا بدي احجي السؤال السؤال السؤال
يطرح نفسه قول لي قاسم سليماني شنو وضعه
بالعراق ا افهم شو له علاقه قاسم سليماني
بالعراق شو يسوي يفتر بالعراق وياخذ صور
قال هذه العامري وحكى بالمكان وقائد الجيش
الشعبي وقائد الحشد شنو علاقه قاسم
سليماني وين الدوله العراقيه وين رئيس
الحكومه العراقيه الجيش خليني بالجيش خل
هذا هو الجيش الجيش اليوم قاسم سليماني هو
رئيس الاركان قاسم سليماني هو هو وزير
الدفاع قاسم سليماني هو القائد العام قوات
المسلحع قاسم سليماني وهادي العامري هم
ينسقون اليات
وهم واحد جاي يجي يدافع عنك وعن مقدسات وع
قاسم سليماني قاسم سليماني مرحب منكل
العراقين
مجرم حب خلين بالجيش خليني بالجيش
لا لا خليني بالجيش بالجيش العراقي بالله
ما تاخذني بعيد عن الموضوع الموضوع ببساطه
شديده هذا هو التسليح اللي ايران تفقد على
الجيش انا اروك التسليح تفضل يا دكتور
فرجيه على الكاميرا يعني شو يعني شو شوف
التسليح هذه الاسلحه المتطوره حتى تشوفون
ايش قاعد يصير بالعراق شوف لاحظ لاحظ خلي
اخر مخرج
يشوف
مجدات هذه الاسلحه ما موجوده عند الجيش
العراقي هذه الاسلحه جايه من ايران طيب
تساعدكم ايران لا ما ساعدنا
ايران سعدنا يا دكتور يا اخي ما يصير هذا
الوضع ما يصير انت وضعك شنو انت يعني شنو
ايران الوضع ببساطه شديده ايران جاي تحتل
العراق وتديم احتلال العراق
وتريد نعم جيشها الخاص وتنطلق الى سوريا
وتنطلق للمملكه العربيه السعوديه ببساطه
شديده وانت الحقيقه انت انسان يعني ماخذك
الاتجاه واضح جدا مغسول دماغك مسوي لك اي
نعم مغسول غسل دم انس
الانح
الانش داعش ارهابين
الخرايط الحكه السوديه
ممكن اسالك
ل يا
[موسيقى]
سيد